if you were with Jill I think you would
try to achieve dan Bilzerian level but
yeah so he's probably Mourdock and I'm
Joe exotic for sure dr. Antle yeah I see
him being a dan Bilzerian two seconds
yes really
maybe not that way but more like a
robotic way at what specific age would
you guys consider like okay at this very
exact age that is old doesn't change as
you get older yeah that person is old oh
I'm pretty [ __ ] old okay so like
think I'll go like not like oh I'm so
old then as a kid I would watch friends
I'm like those guys are adults right
right and now that like I'm either that
age or older than them depending on that
I think over 40
I'm still pretty [ __ ] yeah the game
like old age or 374 me 77 do like a
senior sister so once you hit 70 you're
gonna be like well because I've seen
some pretty able-bodied 60s even 65 I'm
gonna sleep on 70 yours like 65 Rose are
still running and doing all kinds of
crazy [ __ ]
it is funny though when I'm on [ __ ]
tick-tock and I see like a 14 year old
kid be like oh I'm getting so old
I'm like bro shut up [ __ ] that was us
dude that was us let me double check
okay
no you need sorry I know no the sound is
fine as the airplane because they
conducted this poll where they were
asking people like certain questions so
for example at what exact age would you
prefer would you describe old as having
a heightened concern about overall
health
Oh age would that be now like taking
care of yourself more because you're old
you're like things are going bad and
even if things are falling apart like my
knees are when you have to regularly
check your prostate
you know what age you're supposed to
check 40s already supposed to I have an
525 or so yeah I'm not even concerned
yet so I'm you don't even know 25 no I
want to try process
coming it is no I just wanted to 100% 45
for prostate Oh like colon cancer at 45
is when you have to get tested and if a
breast cancer is 40 if your [ __ ]
these two are checked for colon cancer
absolutely okay before each step you
should especially check true is the
official age for seniors 65 plus yes all
right that's what seniors 55 really yeah
sometimes like certain restaurants but
no like like to get your benefits or
whatever is when you pull out your
stocks and all that stuff or I don't
know your retirement yeah 60 people
retiring early and early by the time we
get there would be 75 maybe they keep
wanting to move it I thought it was
moving younger because everyone I talk
to they're like yeah I'm trying to
retire by 55 maybe 50 23 I thought life
was over
cuz I'm already old and I haven't
accomplished [ __ ] I feel that every year
they're getting old man I'm old this
year next year I'm old a okay I just
feel like I'm a grandpa trapped in a
young man's body I try to have a good
mindset about it because I feel like my
life has gotten so much better as I've
gotten all yeah I feel like I'm a child
I feel like I'm getting closer to my
puberty or prime or whatever that's
gonna be and I feel like that's gonna
happen maybe when I'm like 45 or 50 I
feel like I'm at the perfect age where
you're still young enough to like hang
out and party with twenty year olds but
then you're old enough to where you
accomplished enough and you made enough
money and and and and you could you have
the health and you could run around but
then you also get the respect of 40 50
year olds and you can sit in the
meetings with them it's a perfect age I
think you say that and then you show up
to a college party and that one's like
oh this is old [ __ ] oh okay I don't want
a party with like 20 year olds I want a
party with like 25 year olds okay one
goes to Vegas one drinks at a friend's
house frat party yeah I'm hearing some
when they're out of the house I'm so
bummed that we don't get to like live in
the generation where they're gonna have
to be
chips and [ __ ] I know me too I always
tell lies like I'm like you're so lucky
you have a whole like generation before
me you might get to explore space and
[ __ ] you might be able to fly
commercially I'm like I'm jealous of
your children Isaac I want to be what do
you want me to do you know the Futurama
they save your head huh and you just get
to live like that what you want to do
most of the times you're just sitting on
a shelf next to other people's heads and
you're just but they're famous and cool
people that's true I'll say half my dick
and you copy your brain though I would
copy my brain and put it in another body
that's not me that's like me but that's
not me if they make a copy of all the
dice on it but you don't know that it's
not you if it's a copy that means that
it can be two of you but what don't you
miss your dick though like your original
has died and but your you still live on
because you are now a copy of your what
if he's better than you'll ever be
he's the best Nelson that could ever
have happened and then that and that
version of you would know exactly why
god of yours that you're saying but I
don't want people to know that I can be
better I want them to think this is the
best version of him that can possibly
exist I'm like that's true you think
this is how they pitched that dog [ __ ]
Will Smith movie which one I am Legend
he's like the Will Smith versus young
Will Smith Gemini man Terminator men
they did that movie previously I rather
just die if I can't have my dick if I'm
a robot
think about it and you're conscious
right and you're just gonna miss your
body what if you give you a robot dick
well that's fine if you could feel it
you feel the same feel everything if it
feels even better
oh hell yeah different nerves oh oh
you're talking my dream what if you
could adjust the size of your dick
depending on your mood today's a big day
yeah sometimes I want to make love to
Nicky and so it's like you know I don't
need to be a dick big dick man but then
sometimes I'm like you all want that I
don't have the biggest [ __ ] dick in
this house jackhammer her yeah they're
just it all the way up the slider your
ass no pal that's really cool actually
an adjustable dig site not just well you
can with the the the info on that
I like you okay this sounds perfect fit
a good Will Smith movie yeah dog
okay back to this poll here so they they
concluded here that people consider
themselves to be old at the age of 57 so
the heightened concern about overall
health is that thirty nine percent of
people said at that age as well as a
variety of more aesthetic concerns such
as wrinkles weight gain gray hair hair
loss and age spots so these are all
those are kind of cool things though age
spots can [ __ ] off that's my own name I
like the Restless but age spots really
pretty weird look at the difference
between some balls and like they're all
like the big moles yeah they're all like
four hediye and then they like you would
take your hands and they're just dots
all over the place yeah maybe that is
but it just grows oh yeah you know what
you look at old person's hands and it
looks like they have palms on both sides
all stretched out and it's like it's
weird-looking
they look like walking testicles yeah
it's like stretched and wrinkly at the
same time it's like that weird look yeah
cuz um well more of the questions here
is uh the fear of not being able to take
care of yourself I want people to take
care of me you want someone to wipe your
ass for you I want people to feed me I
just want to be treated like a king like
a baby like if I can't wipe my own ass
or feed myself I wanted to it oh right I
want to just die what if you can't do it
but they got a robot to do it for you I
can't do it myself I'm dead like that's
it that's the end of my life I need to
go I'm out I can barely do that now so
I'm gonna dress well I mean now that
I've been spoiled by my bday I have to
poop here yesterday and I was like oh my
I forgot how to do this how many squares
do I use weights is your butt they dry
your ass or decent as a dryer because I
have a drawer you too and then there you
run it twice and then you accept some
moisture you have to wait there for five
minutes you're in the future I think you
have actually moved into the future when
it comes to the toilet and we're all in
the pastel because you're what you're
talking about that sounds way more
convenient you don't have to do it I
don't even use paper at all yeah
especially because of the quarantine I'm
like I don't want to have to think about
the fact that I'm running out of toilet
paper so why use that commodity he's an
only adopter of the wet ass I don't like
what asked Casey I want to hear what
you're gonna say pinions to because I
don't know I concluded maybe it was
nasty
but remember when I was like hey what if
we have a designated ass towel in the
bathroom
tonight we're asses I don't like the day
I thought about that but I was like well
to share I don't know like each like why
not but just you got to tell the guests
when they come over so they don't think
it's a hand-tied my blood towel right no
we have our own toilet rooms now in this
new house
oh then in that case why not in this
toilet room would it be disgusting oh
it's gonna be gross because like as
clean as you yes with toilet paper as
clean as you can spray your ass with a
bidet it'll never be as clean as using
[ __ ] soap in a shower and scrubbing
the [ __ ] out of your ass you're right
I'm with Casey it's gotta be there's
always gonna be some sort of [ __ ]
residue on your yeah you're not putting
out high enough pressure no but not so
you would add some pressure yeah if you
put a hurt when you pressure wash your
driveway do you need soap no think about
it I've had incidents where I used up a
day and then I wipe my ass with a
t-shirt the toilet paper and there's
still a streak there and I go I have to
blast it again so if that was a cotton
towel and there's a caucus streak I
would be very discount push out and
stream is what I breathe I hope that is
a very person
I also did yeah and then when you're
wiping you're like no you relax and let
it fill up like a balloon up and then
you shoot it out and that's what I do
Steve have you ever actually used the
day before I'm having Vegas you're the
kind of guy that wouldn't not ever adopt
it you know what I'm American but day or
no Western birthday is more is more
it's more relaxed let me tell you
something all right super day I had
nothing but hate for it nothing but hey
okay as a as a traditional southern
person perhaps would feel about gay
people until he met one it was like that
for me I was like I don't think so
get that thing out of here I was in a
Vegas hotel they had the most executive
one I tried it I loved it do you ever
here's the one like in whenever you
visit us or like in the other office I
don't because I don't know how to use it
but in the Vegas like 50 yeah in Vegas
it was so [ __ ] easy they had the the
button was like surrounded by that
beautiful blue light I had to press it I
had to press it so yeah it was awesome
and all the one with with with like two
toilets you know how to stand up and
went over and on the Europeans to put
your penis down and then how do they dry
themselves do they have a designated ask
towel I think so I have a towel that you
just use once and put it in a hamper
I also discovered that I can handle a
lot of pressure a lot of them I thought
what interesting you got a time you
played with it you played with the dial
and really helped more pressure a lot
more pressure need more power
Bart is it true that you had a poop
knife huh poop knife didn't you have a
poop right what's the poop that maybe
aren't you the pooping I forget where
you had a poop so big you felt like you
had to cut it so you had a so you could
cut up the poopy you remember it better
than mine it's out familiar right it's
so familiar
because it sounds like I would remember
the specific sorry cuz I'm very proud
when the poop comes out and it comes out
of the wallet yeah cuz sometimes it's
like a beached
folks out of the water yeah
you want team sixteen inches and it's
like it's like it's like sticking out
now my Wow or clock sounds like hey one
that happens then you know for sure it's
gonna have it leave a [ __ ] stain out to
you yeah push the toys yeah flush your
toys
I've had that before I love how that's
all relatable yeah yeah why is that a
thing for all guys to be like - yup
rusty doesn't agree but I I know you're
talking about I'm not gonna do that
though
[Music]
[Music]